So let's go through some of
these Gestalt Principles.
The first is the Law of Past Experience.
Early apps and
mobile platforms took advantage of this
by sowing you digital versions of
things from the physical world,
like notepads, stop watches,
and weekly planners.
The lines on the paper of a notepad app
are sometimes referred to
as skeuomorphic details.
They're ornamental decorations that
can make the UI feel a little more
comfortable and familiar to the user.
As mobile devices became more and
more prevalent, it became less and
less useful to incorporate
these kinds of details.
People became more and
more comfortable using apps that
didn't exactly look like their
real world counterparts.
And how about the Law of Proximity?
Returning to the example from our quiz,
these boxes representing text are close
to these circles that are likely images.
They're closeness tells us instinctively
that they must be related.
The text is probably the label for
the image.
Even without knowing what each
item says, we won't mistake
the relation between this and
this with something like this and this.
We can also recognize that these
three items are close to each other
while the others aren't.
This helps us further visually
deconstruct what's going on in
this screen.
Finally, we can take this a step
further with the Law of Similarity, and
recognize that each of the items in
this list must represent similar things
because they look basically the same.
The cool thing is, all we did here to
set up these relationships was use
white space to our advantage.
Adding more space between elements
separated them both visually and
conceptually.
Tightening the space between
elements help them feel more related
to one another.